شكرا سفيان واهلا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه
النافذه للتحليل العسكري لمجريات حرب
اسرائيل على قطاع غزه نستضيف في هذه
النافذه اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا وسهلا ونتابع
ايضا اخر تطورات المشهد ميدانيا على
الخريطه التفاعليه مع الزميل عبد القادر
عراضه ونبدا بك اذا عبد القادر نعم زين
شكرا ولعل البدايه ربما من التطورات بشكل
اجمالي سواء ما تعلق بالشمال او بجنوب
قطاع غزه وحينما نتحدث عن شمال قطاع غزه
نشير الى ان نتحدث عن مناطق ضللنا نتحدث
دوما عنها بالنظر الى تطوراتها المتلاحقه
سواء ما تعلق بالشجاع ما تعلق بجباليا ما
تعلق ببيت حانون لكن يتعلق الامر بخان
يونس المتحدث العسكري الاسرائيلي وصف ما
يحدث في شمال غزه بانه قتال وصفه بحرب
عصابات في الشمال ووصف ما يحدث في خان
يونس بانها معارك شرسه مع المقاومه لكن
اللافت ايضا هو عمليه الاستهداف التي طالت
خلال اليومين الماضيين المنطقه الوسطى من
خلال استهداف اكثر من مخيم سواء البريج
النصيرات وايضا المغازي بالذهاب ايضا الى
تطور لافت ربما في هذه الحرب وهو اننا
نتحدث عن اليوم الث للحرب الاسرائيليه على
غزه لازالت المقاومه تطلق صواريخها باتجاه
مناطق غلاف غزه نحن نتحدث قت عن اليوم الث
وما زالت المقاومه تصل صواريخها الى غلاف
غزه بل اكثر من ذلك في الايام الماضيه
وصلت الى تلبيب الكبرى وهذا معطى مهم في
الحرب الدائره في غزه لو ذهبنا الى تفاصيل
المشهد ولعلنا ننطلق من المنطقه الشماليه
الاخبار تتحدث عن ما نقلته سرايا القدس عن
استهدافها بدايه ل استهدافها ل منطقه اردز
لقوات اسرائيليه في منطقه اريتس نحن نتحدث
عن هذه المنطقه منطقه اردس استهداف قوه
اسرائيليه في هذه المنطقه وهذا يدل على ان
المقاومه ما زالت تتحرك في هذه المناطق
الشماليه كان هناك ايضا تطور لافت دوما في
المنطقه الشماليه ولكن تحديدا في منطقه
جباليه المقاومه ايضا تتحدث عن استهداف
مركبتين اسرائيليتين هنا في جباليه البلد
وذلك ب صواريخ مضاده للتحصينات ولكن ايضا
كان هناك حديث عن استهداف ايضا لدبابه
ميركافا ولكن هذه المره ربما ننتقل الى
جنوبا نوعا ما الى منطقه الشجاعيه دبابه
ميركافا هنا بصاروخ تنوم اطلقته المقاومه
في منطقه الشجاعيه نلاحظ بانه تحرك
المقاومه كما لاحظنا في المناطق الشماليه
يذهب الى جنوب منطقه غزه كان هناك ايضا
استهداف على المقاومه سواء سرايا القدس او
كتائب القسام عن استهداف لحشود عسكريه هنا
في منطقه الزيتون وتحديدا في شرق حي
الزيتون واللافت هو في جحر الديك جحر
الديك التي لطالما تحدثنا عنها هذه
المنطقه التي تعد منطقه رخوه
وشكلت شكلت منطقه توغل اسرائيلي الى هذه
المناطق تحدثت القسام عن استهدافها لتجمع
لقوه متحصنه في هذه المنطقه وذلك بصواريخ
مضاده للافراد ولل التحصينات اذا المقاومه
لازالت تبادر في منطقه جحر الديك نلاحظ
بان جحر الديك كانت القسام ايضا قد نشرت
مقاطع فيديو لاستهداف قوات في هذه المنطقه
طبعا ياتي ذلك ايضا كما قلت اضافه الى
عمليه القصف التي طالت المناطق الوسطى
سواء النصيرات او البريج او حتى مخيم
المغازي اين ارتكبت مشجره ذهب ضحيتها اكثر
من 100 شهيد بالذهاب الى المنطقه الجنوبيه
وتحديدا في منطقه خان يونس نحن نتحدث ايضا
عن ما نقلته كتائب القسام وسريا القدس عن
تحركات لها في المنطقه الشرقيه اشتباكات
دوما مستمره في هذه المنطقه مع محاولات
التقدم الاسرائيلي القسام تحدثت عن
استهداف ناقله جون في المنطقه الشرقيه
لخان يونس ولكن هناك استهداف ايضا ل قوى ل
تجمعات او حشود اسرائيليه هنا في المنطقه
الشماليه لخان يونس ياتي ذلك في ظل
محاولات التقدم دوما نحو مدينه خانيونس
ربما بالعوده الى المنطقه الشماليه تحديدا
لابد ان نشير الى تطور لافت تمت الاشاره
اليه وهذا التطور تحديدا في منطقه الش
رضوان حيث نقل ايضا من خلال من خلال ما
نشرته الجزيره عن معاناه السكان في مناطق
شرق الشيخ رضوان عن عمليه انسحاب لقوات
اسرائيليه من شرق منطقه الشيخ رضوان في
هذه المناطق لا ندري دلاله هذه الانسحابات
لعل التحليل العسكري هو الذي سيعطي مزيد
من التفسير حول هذه التطورات سواء في
الشمال او في الجنوب ما حدث في جحر الديك
ولكن ايضا في شرق الشيخ رضوان شكرا عبد
القادر وهذا بالفعل ما نتناوله مع اللواء
فايز الدويري هذا الانسحاب لافت رغم ان
هنالك محاولات للتقدم في محاور عده كما
شاهدنا في الخريطه التفاعليه مع عبد
القادر يعني ما الذي يحكم الانسحاب هل
عاده حسب ما نفهم يتم الانسحاب اذا تحقق
الهدف او اذا لم يعد من الممكن تحقيقه
يعني بالنسبه لحاله ما يجري بعد طوفان
الاقصى اعتقد ان مفهوم الانسحاب لم يكن
ضمن الاجنده الاسرائيليه كان الحديث عن
الاحتلال والحديث عن التهجير الى غير ذلك
لنعد الى المربع الاول والاسبوع الاول هذا
الامر هذه المصطلحات تغيرت وادخلت على
مسار المعركه لكن اجابه على
سؤالك
لماذا يعيد الان انتشاره وتموضع تحت عنوان
رئيسي يمكن ان يسمى الانسحاب ام هناك عده
معطيات هذه المعرك
هذه المعركه معركه طوفان الاقصى وبعد 56
يوم من المعركه البريه و 80 يوم من الحمله
الجويه ماذا حقق ماذا انجز عسكريا غير
عمليه التدمير وارتكاب الموبقات في حق
المدنيين العزل لكن في المقاربه العسكريه
ماذا حقق هل سيطر على كيلومتر مربع واحد
الان اجتمعت عده عوامل اجتمعت عده عوامل
لانه الانسحاب حتى في في
وانت طبعا سيدي العارفين هو له اثر سلبي
على القوات المقاتله اي ما كان هي حالات
الانس ينحب الانسحاب يفرض للتخلص اولا من
معركه فاشله من حيث المبدا القاعده
الرئيسيه لا تنسحب اي قوات من منطقه ما
الا الحاله الرئيسيه في اثناء انا اتحدث
عن اثناء المعركه وليس عن انتهاء الحرب في
حاله
القتال الانسحاب يكون التخلص من معركه
خاسره او اعاده انتشار القوات لمساعده
منطقه اخرى في هذه الحاله لا ينطبق
عليها اي من الحالتين الحاله الثانيه لا
تنطبق لوفره القوات لكن في الحاله الاولى
هو اجبر على الانسحاب لجمله عوامل هذه
المعركه انت سالت عن طبيعه هذه المعركه
هذه المعركه مختلفه
مختلفه وح وليذهب كل من يبحث في العلم
الاست الاستراتيجي ان يجد لها مثيل هذه
هناك مرتكزات عده جعلتها متميزه اولا هذه
حرب غير متناظره الجيش رقم 18 عالميا
الرابع في القدرات
التكنولوجيه يدخل حرب لا
متناظره مع
فصائل تم اعداد الفرد والجماعه والقوه
كامله
بصوره مثاليه الى حد كبير عقديا بدنيا
مهنيا احترافيا تحدث كما تشاء اذا هو دخل
الى عش الدبابير وعليه ان يدفع الثمن
النقطه الاخرى ليست فقط حرب غير متناظره
بين جيش وجماعات لا انما هي داخل المدن
وتاريخيا هذا الجيش ليس لديه الخبره في
قتال المدن العنصر الثالث هذه المره
الاولى التي يفصل سطح الارض والقشره
الارضيه بين المهاجم والمدافع ا لو اخذنا
خط شاقولي في اي نقطه قد يكون الجندي من
جيش الاحتلال يقف عموديا مع ط وذكرت
الاستعداد وطبعا الاسرائيليين تحدثوا عن
استعدادات مقاتل القسام وقالوا نحن لا نخذ
حربا مع جماعات ارهابيه وانما مع خبراء
وهذا الفيديو لاستهداف اليات الاحت بقذائف
ومزل منزل يتحصنون فيه بقذيفه التي بي جي
المضاده للتحصينات التي نشرته القسام
اليوم وفي هذا الفيديو اظن هنالك دعوه لك
للتحليل ساحل حلل يا دويري ساحل اه نعم
الان لنعد الى بعض الفيديوهات التي نشرت
عن تصنيع المعدات العسكريه السؤال المطروح
اليست غزه محاصره من عام 86 بصوره عامه
اليس حصارها
مطبق منذ 2013 بصوره جازمه قاطعه في هذه
الفتره كيف
استعدت تبنت مقاربه الهندسه العكسيه وهي
التي تجيز ودول الصين الهند تتبنى مقاربه
الهندسه العسكريه بحيث تقوم
بمحاكاه الاسلحه المتاحه والمتميزه
وتصنعها دون ان تاخذها كما يقال كوبي بيست
ومن مصدر محدوده اذا هذه المقاومه ولاحظنا
بع بعض التصوير تصنيع بندقيه قمس الغول
كانت كمثال واضح دعني اقول من العدم صنعوا
شيء جماعات مقاتله تعدوا بالالاف وقفوا
ليس امام جيش اسرائيل الم يهرع العالم
الغربي بزعامته
وقياداته
ليعيدوا احياء ذلك الجسد المتهالك والذي
سقط في السابع من اكتوبر اذا هذه هي تعقيد
المعركه وهو صدق عندما قال
معركه مركبه
نعم اشاره سريعه المنطقه الشماليه المركبه
ومعقده نعم هي مرك وانا اوضحت ل سب سبب
لماذا هي مركبه الان
الخارطه نحن نشاهد الفيديو المنطقه
الشماليه وعرضت الخرائط بكثره الان الجيش
جيش الاحتلال تقريبا بصوره ترقى الى
80% تراجع من الكتله كتله المباني واصبح
في المناطق الزراعيه كما يقال نعم كانه
هذه المنطقه من العطاطه بيت لاهيا بيت
حانون تل الزعتر حتى الدخول جنوب جباليا
هذه المنطقه هي التي يتواجد فيها يعني كان
انا اقول بالمثل الشعبي كانك يا ابو زيد
ما غزيت كل ما فعلته تراج جعت عنه بقيت لك
بعض القوات المتواجده في الشيخ رضوان
ستقوم بسحبها من منطقه الفالوجه هو تراجع
لانه انجز بحسب بحسب المتحدث العسكري لنا
ننقل ما يقول يقول المتحدث العسكري دمرنا
عشرات الانفاق
وقتلنا الالاف من مقاتلي حماس نحن نتحدث
عن انفاق غزه التي حسب التقديرات
الاسرائيليه تزيد عن 500 ك م من الانفاق
يتحدث عن تدمير عشرات الانفاق ما الذي
يعنيه ذلك في الانجاز يعني على مستوى سلم
الانجاز حسب المعلومات التي استطعنا ان
نصل لها وهي تحمل درجه مصداقيه عاليه ان
شاء الله اولا عدد الانفاق 1300 نفق يوجد
570 م م منها ما هي طابق واحد وطابقين
وثلاثه طوابق منها منها انفاق تستخدم
لغايه مح حدده ك النفق الذي اكتشف و عند
معبر ايرس والذي كتبت القسام وصلت متاخرا
المهمه انجزت له بدايه ونهايه ما عرض من
افلام من افلام قدمها جيش الاحتلال نعم هي
انفاق لكن هذه الانفاق هي ليست الانفاق
الدفاعيه هي ليست الانفاق الهجوميه هي
انفاق للخدمات
منامات مناطق تكديس ذخيره الى غير ذلك
لانه عندما صممت الانفاق الان اذهب الى
البعد التحليلي عندما صممت الانفاق سممت
لتحقيق غايات معينه وبالتالي د نشاهد هذه
الصور ايضا ونعلق اللواء فايز هذه الصور
لتمشيط اللواء الرابع الاسرائيلي
لمناطق واسعه في خان يونس هو لا هذا في
شرق خان بهذه الصور يقول انه فرض السيطره
او هذا الفيديو الذي كنا نتحدث عنه الم
يقل انه سيطر على جحر الديك في قبل 56 يوم
والان شاهدنا فيديو في جحر الديك اذا
مفهوم السيطره من حيث الواقع غير موجود ا
انما عندما نتحدث عن الانفاق فقط اود ان
اوضح نقطه المخطط الذي صمم الانفاق كان
لديه حس امني راقي جدا هكذا اقرا فصل بين
انفاق العمليات للاغراض الدفاعيه
والهجوميه
وانفاق الخدمات اللوجستيه ولا يعقل ان
توضع شبكه الانفاق كالاو المستطرقه بحيث
اذا اكتشفت نفق تستطيع التنقل في في 1300
نفق هذا امر غير موجود لو كان ذلك صحيحا
لا اغرقت الانفاق وتم حل المشكله علما
يحتاج نصف مياه البحر المتوسط كما يقال
مجازا اذا دعني اقول الانسحاب تحت الاكراه
والانسحاب اذا لاحظنا الفيديوهات التي
التي تمت في هذا اليوم لماذا يستخدم
الستار الدخاني سؤال والعسكريين يجب ليطر
لماذا ستخدم لانه لا يست عندما عندما تريد
ان تخلي موقعا في حاله اشتباك هناك اليات
معينه احد هذه الاليات انا اوفر سترا
دخانيه لاخفي حركاتي وامنع الى حد كبير
النيران المسدده من الذي اجبرني على
الانسحاب تمام يعني السؤال ايضا الذي يطرح
نفسه حتى هذه اللحظه يعني انت تتابع
المعركه منذ 56 يوما كل كل فيديوهات
القسام فيها جنود اسرائيليين يتم
استهدافهم كل فيديوهات الجيش الاسرائيلي
هل فيها فيديو واحد في في مقاتل ف انا
شاهدت وحللت جميع الفيديوهات وانا اقول
هذه الفيديوهات نعم اجريت وتم تصويرها في
غزه تم تصويرها قطعا في غزه لكن كيف اذا
لو نعود الى الخارطه واللون الاصفر وصل
الى اعماق كبيره في بعض الحالات وصل الى
ساحه فلسطين الان العمق من سحه فلسطين الى
شارع الرشيد تصل الى حوالي 3 ك م اي نصف
المسافه المناطق الخلفيه لم تعد المقاومه
بها بنفس الدرجه التي تتعامل بمئات
الامتار الاولى هنا استطاع ان يدخل الىى
الانفاق هنا استطاع ان يحضر جنوده ويقوم
بتصوير كانهم يخوضوا معركه دفاعيه وانا
قلت سابقا يعني في احد المشاهد التي حاولت
نسب تهمه الارهاب لجماعات معينه بعد
انتهاء التصوير قال لهم المصور انهضوا
انتهى التصوير وهنا كنت اتمنى ان يغفلوا
ان الكاميرا مفتوحه ويقول لجنوده توقفوا
عن اطلاق النار انتهى التصوير اشكرك شكرا
جزيلا اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي ختام هذه الفقره العسكريه
الخاصه بحرب اسرائيل على غزه نعود الى
غرفه الاخبار لمواصله التغطيه معك وسيله